so I have this somewhat hairy function
definition here and I want to see if we
can graph it and this is a piecewise
function it's defined as a different
essentially different lines you see this
right over here even with all the
decimals of the negative signs this is
essentially a line it's defined by this
line over this interval for X this line
over this interval of X and this line
over this interval of X let's see if we
can graph it and encourage you
officially if you have some graph paper
to see if you could graph this on your
own first before I work through it so
let's think about this first interval if
one negative 10 is less than or equal to
X which is less than negative 2 then our
function is defined by negative zero
point one two five X plus four point
seven five so this is going to be a line
as downward sloping line and the easiest
way I can think about graphing it is
let's just plot the the end points here
and then draw the line so when X is
equal to 10 so when our sir when X is
equal to negative 10 so we would have
negative zero actually let me write it
this way let me do it over here where I
do the so we're going to have negative
0.125 times negative 10 plus four point
seven five that is going to be equal to
let's see the negative times a negative
is a positive and then 10 times this is
going to be it's going to be one point
two five plus four point seven five that
is going to be equal to six
so we're going to have the point
negative 10 comma six and that point and
it includes so X is defined that's less
than or equal to and then we go all the
way to negative two so when X is equal
to negative two we have negative 0.125
times negative two plus four point seven
five is equal to see negative times
negative is positive two times this is
going to be point is going to be
positive 0.25 plus four point seven five
it's going to be equal to positive five
now we might be tempted we might be
tempted to just circle in this dot over
here but remember this interval does not
include negative two it's up to it
including it's up to negative two not
including so I'm going to put a
a I'm going to put a little open circle
there and then I'm going to draw the
line and then I'm going to draw and I'm
going to draw the line I am going to
draw my best attempt my best attempt at
the line now let's do the next interval
the next interval this was a lot more
straightforward we started x equals
negative two when x equals negative two
negative two plus seven is negative 2
plus 7 is 5 so negative 2 so negative 2
comma 5 so it actually includes that
point right over there so we're actually
able to fill it in and then when X is
negative 1 negative 1 plus 7 is going to
be positive 6 positive 6 but we're not
including x equals negative 1 up to and
including
so it's going to be it's going to be
right over here when X is negative 1 we
are approaching or as X approaches
negative 1 we're approaching negative 1
plus 7 is 6 so that's that interval
right over there
and now let's look at this last interval
this last interval when X is negative 1
you're going to have well this is just
going to be positive 12 over 11 because
we're multiplying it by negative 1 plus
54 over 11 which is equal to 66 over 11
which is equal to positive 6 so we're
able to fill in that right over there
and then when X is equal to 10 you have
negative 120 over 11 I just multiplied
this times 10 12 times 10 is 120 and we
have the negative plus 54 over 11 so
this is the same thing this is going to
be what is this this is negative 66 over
11 is that right let's see if you that
is negative 66 over 11 which is equal to
negative 6 so when X is equal to 10 our
function is equal to negative negative 6
and so this one actually doesn't have
any jumps in it it could've but we see
so there we have it we have graphed this
function that has been defined in a
piecewise way